what's interesting is the more that we
fight back on this stuff the more that
we push on them they slowly start
admitting that they made it all up and
that they don't know what the flying f
that they're doing uh you may remember
this from a couple weeks ago fauci
basically saying he doesn't even know if
lockdowns work i'm interested in your
reluctance to use the word lockdown do
you think two years on that they were
worth it or were they too severe
you know i don't think we're ever going
to be able to determine what the right
balance is i think the restrictions if
you want to use that word which i tend
to shy away from
lockdown this certainly prevented a lot
of infections prevented a lot of
hospitalizations
and prevented a lot of deaths there's no
doubt
about that
obviously when you do have that kind of
restriction on society
there are unintended
negative consequences particularly in
children who are not allowed to go to
school
in the psychological and mental health
aspects it has on children
in the economic stress that it puts on
society in general on individual
families
obviously those are negative
consequences that are unintended
or are they intended because you people
are control freaks who are destroying
trying to destroy the known world so
that you could build back better or
whatever else it is that you're trying
to do right now at the world economic
forum right like i think i think people
are starting to see
what is up here also there's just no
evidence he says the lockdowns obviously
he says obviously they obviously stop
death i mean we just don't know that we
don't know that they obviously stopped
infection well i suppose to some degree
if you completely lock everybody down
it's going to stop some degree of
infection but whatever happened to that
herd immunity thing where you'd want
young healthy healthy people to get
covet and all that stuff so you guys get
it you guys get it i'm only reiterating
all this because i want to show you that
they just don't know what they either
don't know what they're doing or they're
completely inept or they're evil it's
one of those things but we either way we
cannot forget what they did let's jump
back to last november when joe biden was
warning us about the winter of death and
trying to scare the hell out of all of
us and making sure that first responders
who used to be essential they were going
to be fired if they didn't get
vaccinated
first
we must increase vaccinations among the
unvaccinated with new vaccination
requirements
with nearly 80 million eligible
americans who have not gotten vaccinated
many said they were waiting for approval
from the food and drug administration
the fda
well last month the fda granted that
approval
so the time for waiting is over
this summer we made progress through the
combination of vaccine requirements and
incentives as well as the fda approval
four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
man isn't it something like once you see
what [ __ ] artists these people are
once you really see it once you accept
it and know it like you cannot see the
world any other way that's what their
ultimate red pill is once you know it
then you watch a video like that which
you guys all saw that video that's from
eight months ago right we all saw that
and when he says it's not about personal
freedom and it's not about what is it he
says it's not about freedom and personal
choice yes it damn well is you dementra
ridden old fool
that's exactly what it is but he was
trying to scare the hell out of
everybody and you know what happened he
did scare a lot of people and a lot of
people made a horrible choice that they
did not want to make they then got
vaccinated against their conscience and
then what happened the courts fought
against it and they reversed it
so that even though the food and drug
administration said it was okay and he
talked to the people at the labor board
it turned out that it was
unconstitutional to have companies force
people to be vaccinated and once again
as i said a million times during the
height of this whole thing the idea that
i could say to my employees guys you
have to be injected with some
experimental [ __ ] to work for me is that
cool guys after this we're going to take
you downstairs and eject you somewhere
no connor's totally not into it michael
you kind of you didn't give me much
there oh no okay okay he wasn't paying
attention uh
it's just all bananas the point is don't
forget